when Apple first announced the 2020
updates to their 13-inch MacBook Pros we
expected the higher-end
$1,800.00 model to have a decent but not
huge improvement in performance over the
base model
thanks to the new 10th gen processor but
with each test that we ran we were
surprised to see more and more
unexpected advantages and reasons to
spend the extra cash on the $1,800 model
and trust me there are more advantages
than you think but before we get into
that as well as the things that
disappointed me with this new MacBook
Pro I want to mention that this does not
make the $1300 base model a bad MacBook
by no means and explain why in my review
of the base model which you can check
out after this video is over if we go
back and take a look at the differences
between the 2019 models they're honestly
wasn't that big of a difference
performance between the two was so close
that we actually recommended either
buying the 13-inch base model or going
all the way up to the 16 inch MacBook
Pro we told people to simply avoid the
$1,800 model but this year things have
completely changed for starters you're
getting a lot more value at that $1,800
price point where it used to come with
the 256 gigabyte SSD and now comes with
512 where it used to come with eight
gigabytes of RAM and now comes with 16
so if you were to buy the base model and
pick up those same upgrades so it can
match what the $1,800 model already
comes with it'll cost you another $300
bringing the price up to $1,600 just 200
bucks shy of the higher-end model so the
question is what do you get for spending
another $200 and picking up the better
model and the answer is a lot but at the
same time there are a couple of really
big disappointments when you're spending
this much cash but let's first start off
with the hidden differences between the
two MacBook Pro models the higher-end
model actually comes with two cooling
fans compared to only one on the base
model which not only helps cool that
more powerful 10th gen down but it also
leads to less fan noise in most tasks we
notice this difference while using both
of these Mac
with an e GPU set up the big difference
here is that the higher-end model has
two extra vents on the bottom for taking
in cool air so while we were using them
in clamshell mode the base models lack
of extra vents cause the single fan to
run faster and louder at a 5800 rpm
during one of our video editing export
tests compared to only 4000 rpm on the
higher-end model now what you might not
expect is that those extra vents on the
bottom actually help with speaker
quality as well since it allows sound to
go down through those vents and bounce
off of your desk increasing volume and
on top of that it physically has better
speakers as well and you can see that
when you take the back casing off so
here's a quick speaker comparison
between the two
[Music]
[Music]
you can definitely hear louder volume
and better speaker quality with the
$1,800 model one more difference is that
you get two more Thunderbolt 3 ports on
the right hand side with the higher-end
model so you can hook up more devices
but even if you don't plan on using all
4 of the ports it's definitely much more
convenient to be able to plug in your
power connector on either side instead
of just the left side like on the base
model now before we get into how the
tension ship surprised us I want to talk
about the new magic keyboard as I'm sure
you've heard hundreds of times Apple
really hit the jackpot with this
keyboard because it feels so much better
than the previous Butterfly model the
key travel is great but it also feels
much more tactile compared to the old
magic keyboard from the 2015 MacBook
Pros I'm also very glad that we now have
a physical Escape key instead of it
being integrated into the touch bar and
the most important thing of all is that
it's finally back to being reliable
thanks to the traditional scissor switch
mechanism now let's finally get into
that I 510 gentian in terms of raw power
using the Geekbench 5 CPU test we didn't
see that big of a difference compared to
the base models i5 chip but in the more
realistic Cinebench r20 stress test we
saw a much larger difference with a 24%
higher score probably due to the better
cooling thanks to the dual fans so the
difference in performance is already
pretty decent compared to the base model
but we're really stands out is graphics
performance and Geekbench 5s medal test
we saw a pretty huge 48 percent higher
score on the $1,800 model which is a big
deal since graphics performance is the
main limitation in the 13-inch MacBook
Pros now what totally surprised us was
that we saw an even bigger difference in
some real-world tests we did some photo
editing and Lightroom classic and when
rendering 50 edited 42 megapixel RAW
files that $1,800 model took three
minutes and 28 seconds compared to four
minutes and 43 seconds for the base over
35% faster and that's only 50 images
now in our 22nd 4k stabilization test in
Final Cut Pro 10 the $1,800 model was
literally twice as fast as the base
model and inner 5-minute 4k eg BC export
test it was again over twice as fast
finishing in just five minutes and ten
seconds now this massive difference
doesn't really make sense since the raw
graphics performance is only 48 percent
faster not over double like what we saw
in these tests yes we know that the base
model only comes with eight gigs of RAM
compared to 16 on the higher-end model
but that's not enough to warrant this
huge of a difference in performance the
best explanation we could find is that
the $1,800 model gets much faster lpddr4
X Ram it clocks in at three thousand
seven hundred and thirty three megahertz
compared to two thousand 133 megahertz
on the base model and because the
graphics chips are integrated into the
CPU itself they borrow memory from the
system's total RAM which is faster on
the higher ed macbook pro so all of
those things could be why we saw a
couple of tests perform so much better
on the $1,800 model now what we also
know is that these chips pack newer
graphics technology like improved
decoders and other graphics tech for
example the $1,800 model can support
apples 6k Pro display XDR because the
tension chips comes with the latest
version of display stream compression
technology and another piece of new tech
is the fact that the Thunderbolt 3
controller is integrated right into the
CPU whereas the hñ processor and the
base model requires an additional
controller chip to make Thunderbolt 3
work this might not seem like a huge
deal until you see our results from our
a GPU comparison video in quite a few
video editing tests our 5700 xde GPU
barely helped the MacBook Pros
performance but we noticed that the
$1,800 model was able to utilize the
same a GPU much better improving speeds
by almost two times in some tests
compared to relatively small
improvements when connected to the base
model and we think is because of that
new inner
Thunderbolt three technology and that
could also be wide the $1,800 model with
the EGP you got an average of 85 FPS in
our fortnight gaming test compared to an
average of 65 fps on the base model so
this shows that the tangential has a lot
of tricks up its sleeve that we weren't
expecting at all and that's why a
recommendation is that if you can afford
the $1,800 MacBook Pro you should 100%
buy it over the base model but for those
who can't
the $1,300 model will still do a decent
job for a lot of different things and
now let's finally get into the downsides
if you're paying $1,800 for a premium
MacBook Pro from Apple you can at least
expect to get decent Hardware across the
board but the 720p webcam is downright
terrible in 2020 this flaw is sticking
out like a sore thumb now that a lot of
people are forced to work online and
meet up with people using their webcam
so when a three-year-old I phones
FaceTime camera looks leaps and bounds
better than the webcam on a brand new
20/20 MacBook Pro there's a problem and
if the $400 surface go to tablet can
come with a much better 1080p webcam why
can't the $1,800 MacBook Pro now I know
there's the issue of the top lid being
too thin but they could at least update
it with a newer 720p sensor that has
better low-light performance for a
brighter sharper image so hopefully
we'll see Apple address this issue in
next year's MacBook Pro and one more
thing I want to complain about is the
lack of a dedicated graphics chip even
though the new integrated graphics chip
has improved performance by quite a bit
it's still by far the limiting factor
when it comes to performance and you
might think that maybe the 13-inch size
is too thin but the new razor blade self
13-inch is actually slightly thinner
than the MacBook Pro and you can buy it
with a new gtx 1650 TI graphics card for
$1,800 total now I'm sure the reason why
Apple hasn't put a dedicated graphics
chip in the 13-inch is because they want
to push people towards the 16 inch model
but they could at least add it in and
make it a more expensive $300 upgrade
and I'm sure people will still pay for
it so those are my two major complaints
with the $1,800 MacBook Pro but if we're
comparing it to the same model last year
you're actually getting quite a lot more
value and surprisingly great benefits
from the new tension processor which
lead to much better performance than
before so as of right now we definitely
recommend spending the extra cash on
this MacBook Pro instead of the base
model if you can afford it but if you
agree with my disappointments you could
be better off waiting until next year to
see if Apple fixes those issues if you
enjoy this review make sure it's Happ
the like button and click the circle
above to subscribe so you don't miss out
on more videos like this one and make
sure to check out my review of the base
model right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]